mais oublie pas pas Madame les parf
c'est monsieur le
paire
envoyer Madame
parfait
bien profiter d'une petite danse avec
Moi maman
parf
eh bien profite d'un petit avec Moi allez
papa
Give me parfait gal est bien rythmé mame
parfait plaisir a petit danse avec
Très bien
r plaisir un petit danse avec
Moi parfait ce G bien
ry pl un petit danse avec
le plus est
bien plis une petite danse avec mo Madame
parfait pour les B les vous conna très
bien
parf Marie vi avec
Moi parfa les B ou les
Je connais très bien
eh bien madame
parf ton Mari fin par avec un
Au Saint
Bernard
la
le parfait est bon
rythmé plis a petite danse avec Moi
la paire va bien
par un petit danse avec Moi mame parfait
est bien rythmé parf plaisir un petit
danser avec Madame
Parf Madame
parf un dan avec mo Madame parfait quand
pas d'Utilisation
petit derri la cuisine Madame
parfait nous les Grand quand on passe c
moi je fais mo Madame par quand nous
petit derrière la cuisine
Madame
parf les
grand allez
allez
pous Madame parfé c'est gal est bien
Je vais profiter d'une petite danse avec Moi mf
parfait est bien ramé parf plaisir un
petite danse avec Moi Madame parfaite est
bien
rythmé plaisir a petite danse avec Moi
parfa parfa c'est bien
je vais en profiter un petit avec
Moi parfait les Bell ou lesi vous
très connaisseurs
eh bien, maman parf
mar mame par B eux
js
bien avec
un
saintard dit o
laen dit o
les pous papa
ils sont nuls
allez
va va va va
pas à vous
l'aise Merci